Porter's asked the president yesterday
if he bears any responsibility at all
for the fact that he's about to be
impeached no I don't take any zero to
put it mildly nothing was said wrong in
that call to impeach the President of
the United States for that is a disgrace
and it's a mark on our country
Ben Tracy's at the White House where the
president spoke after he sent that angry
letter to House Speaker Pelosi man the
president's tone was scathing by any
definition what was he trying to
accomplish well the president says he
sent this letter so there would be a
permanent record about his thoughts on
impeachment now for days the White House
has been saying that the president is
completely unfazed by being impeached
but clearly this irate letter tells a
different story in it the president says
the Speaker Pelosi you have cheapened
the importance of the very ugly word
impeachment mr. Trump adds that more due
process was afforded to those accused in
the Salem witch trials then in a very
personal attack on the speaker herself
President Trump says he does not believe
she actually prays for him like she has
said she does and writes even worse than
offending the founding fathers you are
offending Americans of faith he then
goes on later to say no intelligent
person believes what you're saying now
speaker Pelosi responded by calling the
president's letter really sick to which
President Trump tweeted last night good
marks and reviews on the letter I sent
Pelosi today she is the worst Gale all
right Ben thank you very much